Davis hands it off to Russell guarded by
Moran
[Applause]
D'Angelo Russell hits nothing but
fossil rejecting the screen got John is
back
floater is good and he was looking for a
call
Charles putting pressure on it opens up
that kickout pass
ashimura and Russell a little pistol
action for the bucket
10 on the shot clock
got to get to work here Russell got jaw
float game pure D'Angelo helping that
cause goes right by Jean Morant
navigating yeah it really needed to give
that ball a faster D'Angelo a little bit
frustrated don't necessarily love that
he showed it but he knows he's feeling
good offensively
Davis off the elbow it's a popular set
for them he posts up
see why it's popular Doris yeah I mean
on this little play between D'Angelo and
Anthony Davis copchar has just got no
shot right he just Sprints into the
paint and that's the difference for me
with the lake they was setting a screen
for him Bane switches on to him we'll
see if Russell gets it up to him there's
your answer
some people forget that coming into this
series they were the hottest team ending
the regular season James with a steal
Russell On Cue got the layup
he's got 12.
[Music]
Russell's got it back from Davis there's
the lob and the finish and one
couples like his impact is much greater
than those eight points on the boards
when you include so they are plus 15
from the three-point line and the lead
is just 14.
the corner keeping them in the game and
D'Angelo Russell doing a lot for the
Lakers this evening started by the
smaller Desmond Bain
kicks it out to Russell the hot hand
rattles it in another three
the ubiquity of Anthony Davis right now
is extremely profound for the Lakers his
presence huge and Mark to me
there's an impact here of Davis
and it's not going to show up in the Box
Store flash into the elbow for A.D out
to Russell three on the clock got to get
busy in launch it's been that type of
night
all right so he's got I think back to
back threes here that we're going to
show you I believe at the end of one
[Music]
the Lakers have come with a requisite
response here
aims for three
Vanderbilt with another opportunity
Russell
championship belt on oh did he but
somebody might want to tell him there's
a couple more series to go before we
start doing that but